all right and we are laughs the last
word with Yvonne tiss returns after a
short hiatus you boxes how're you doing
sir
what's going on pretty good pretty good
okay well I'm doing okay I apologize to
everybody who's gonna listen this
weekend it's one of the reasons my
videos have been on a bit of a hiatus my
voice felt like crapping out a little
bit so I'm over here starting Monday
with a little lemon and honey
in some hot water to try and soothe the
voice but a couple major things happened
so we still wanted to get in here and
talk with everybody but just having some
fun still playing destiny I was kind of
staring at a battlenet screen I'm like
up I was at the time where it can boot
up breath oh don't still haven't done it
so yeah Dusty's been taking my gaming
time and it's kind of off for a couple
days mostly just from feeling a little
ink crap so sorry I just smacked my mic
a little bit there oh good smack I'll go
up but yeah that's kind of mostly been
my week is a little bit of recovery and
off and dealing with this crap but
mostly just watching the insanity in the
community it's been amazing so that's
gonna be awesome reports oh yeah you had
you had yeah we'll get to your week here
in just a little bit which is absolutely
nuts um but no I had so there was what
you would call a microburst not a
tornado but if you look up a microburst
basically it's just like a very cold
pocket goes straight down and basically
kind of smacks an area for a little bit
and we got to experience that
wholeheartedly with a whole bunch of fun
so we've been dealing with some fun
times in the power outage for ours was
out for six hours but then my internet
was out for like four days so four days
was no four no internet I was in the 80s
for a little while so yeah that's going
on so days yeah I'm late and I also feel
like the most white privilige person
ever being like oh no I don't have my
internet God what'd I ever do like you
really feel like you are right oh yeah
it's sad but it's very very true how
dependent we are on it but it's also it
takes a moment to realize then it's like
my condolences go out to so in downtown
Dallas there is a crane that just fell
on top of an apartment building garage
but also straight on a building and one
person I know was killed like six were
interred the apartment building is like
kind of unlivable right now because of
that thing just laying over the top of
it so I have a home I have no property
damage everybody's okay so in the grand
scheme of things like I am very thankful
that was my situation so it takes a
second to be like hey I don't have
internet this is kind of like yeah I'll
just to hang out with my wife it's
totally fine so overall it's kind of
like take a second take a step back and
just be thankful you're waking up every
day because honestly it's something like
you never know like crane could have fun
like I could have been sitting here tree
could have gone smashed and you never
know - so no you gotta be thankful
absolutely thankful what you got no I
respect that now I was definitely
hearing what she was going through and I
was just like man I feel his pain but I
was in the sunny California I listened
to your III podcast it was another great
one over on iron Lords podcast if you
guys want to listen to one that is gonna
give you an idea what that whole world
is like go listen to their post III oh
no but it was just it's like it's at
their best something like the
back-and-forth you had Jeff Gordon on
there who's cool a couple guys from
windows central I did not know he is I
did not know he had that accent coming I
don't know him that well like I've just
looked at him like a little bit on
Twitter I'll see a stuff pop up I'm kind
of seeing him through you had no idea
that his accent was gonna be like oh
okay
UK and a little Germany mixed it was
like it was cool no I was like the
banter on iron Lords podcast I give you
a hard time about it sometimes there
sometimes I want to smack a couple of
them but that's that's what makes the
podcast what it is for you guys and it's
great and that one especially was it was
one of those to where you just listened
back and forth you know crap is gonna
start flying both ways
it was so good so I want to get your
kind of rundown on just kind of what it
was like going to e3 real quick for
everybody who didn't catch your world
and then also kind of when I had the you
know random viewers and stuff on last
week Thank You Prothean Prescott and
bender for popping in I had some fun and
now kind of wanted we had like just you
know on top three things from kind of e3
that you enjoyed it but just on here
since kind of miss that last week it out
you know absolutely man yeah a three man
ain't never it never gets old
it's like it's the Superbowl of gaming I
implore you if you're a hardcore gamer
you have to do at least one III in your
life that means you to go to one I think
I gotta try and find my way to make it
to next year cuz oh man I think the
gloves are gonna come off next year like
if they're gonna go like if it's gonna
be like one of the last consoles
supposedly whatever but if there's a
time to do it like I think next year is
weird when you think you've gotta try it
like if there's something for Holly yeah
you've got to two new consoles Scarlett
ps5 but now I mean generally it's almost
fraternal like you get to see all your
gaming people you know all your brethren
or all the personalities to deal with
the developers I mean they're all in one
area so you're literally could be going
into a restaurant and then it's like oh
there's Jason Schreyer yeah that's it oh
so I got a funny story with that that's
hilarious so what happens is we yeah
we're doing like day two or day three of
coverage of running around we're trying
to do press we're getting a lot of
behind-the-scenes stuff and oh sure the
cyberpunk oh my god that game's amazing
but um yeah that's a whole different day
so we're making I'm going to
appointments and stuff and I forgot why
I stopped off and I'm with Laura
sovereign and sovereigns like yo that's
Jason Shire and I'm like oh yeah that's
what's up so we go see him and then
right next to him is even to Tolo from
kotaku and I'm like alright cool we got
the energy I see here and everything and
then what's funny is I'm sowing great
grossed like just talking with these
guys
deej is standing right there to the
right
and I'm like ignoring these like yes I
smack smack smack
for that yeah oh yo its place oh you
guys cuz we had a shirt so he's like oh
I love the shirt you guys are Lords you
know you guys is a destiny I'm like oh
hell yeah it started as a destiny
podcast we're going at it Yatta Yatta
Yatta
did you see there like it's anybody
gonna acknowledge me oh my god DS oh my
bad girl and it was a proto vids I'm
like deeds is awesome like first of all
he is so cool so smooth
what-you-see-is-what-you-get the king of
sarcasm I think it just was a cucumber
probably and so smooth I'm just gonna
stand here let you guys talk never mind
me so there's another Bungie dev as well
but yeah deej I'm like bro Guardian Khan
and last we're gonna be there we
definitely got a link-up so we'll see
what happens you know working on some
things behind the scene before me any
boxes we'll see what happens but it'll
be awesome to do something with them
because again in my opinion he's one of
the better Community Managers you know
in all of gaming forget destiny a little
at a man has a gift and avoiding
marketing question you know anything
good he's always so good he's so Eddie
smooth we smooth jazz out there just
dancing oh how can be beat yo I felt I
had to apologize I met just like my
third time being these but on a judge I
would humble brag but I you he's a cool
dude man you got you gotta meet him and
um here's what just a general woody
three is just like I said you you're
going from conference to conference
you're trying to get as much coverage as
you can you know and one thing about it
like I said it's just the Super Bowl
just the ambience
you're the lighting you go and you're
sitting in the conference rooms and you
know the ubisoft's the Bethesda and the
Microsoft and so on and so forth and
it's just like a show it's just and it's
very mesmerizing so that part is cool as
far as like top three moments you want
like games just what bit three big
standouts that's all I'm just trying to
do that points I mean I know the one you
were in there for by the way glad it
worked
oh yes yes how wet how how big is that
theater and then where did you end up
inside theater alright so the you know
shadowy
they made love main things happen for me
allegedly supposed are it's huge it's
huge and you know that is magical
because the lighting just just again
it's there's no bigger show than e3 and
Microsoft and Sony tend to have the best
productions as far as a conference ain't
goin to a stage and so on so yeah man
that that's definitely up there now
we'll say this but des des knows how to
throw a show I was gonna see a party I
heard they got you guys drunk oh yeah
yeah but as soon as we come in you got
your open bar right it's just like they
get your nice before you see gay they
put you at a nice frame of mind cuz
you've been waiting outside it gets you
so that's two and then third I didn't
get a chance to do square this year
obviously something wasn't there um PC
gaming show is actually pretty cool I
didn't like this year's particularly
just the content but to show itself the
hosts they always do it like one of
these cool schwanke kind of theaters
almost like a little Opera House kind of
theater with us at second balcony kind
of anger very gothic yeah very cool
shout out to uh Sean Plott aka day9 that
man knows how to host a conference man
and PC games sure like I said for the
most part it's always one of the more
fun shows they bring devs up they talk
about what's going on epic story had a
huge presence that's another story
but of yeah man I really really enjoyed
so those probably like my three personal
ones as far as conferences I was like
for me I was like I'm gonna no you guys
shattered it out I know somebody's
definitely just lying to himself but
Nintendo crushed it oh oh yeah someone
you know how someone just couldn't Bend
me oh yeah that was like it's it's like
oh yeah but no like for me breadth of
the wilds amazing so that one it'd be
and just like oh just set off everything
I was just like oh hit me in the Zelda
feels right there yeah ghazal de sel
does one of my huge huge forevers from
8-bit gold cartridge zelda wow that's
that's where I started Zelda it was like
no one so I've been do it like you know
grind enough time get the two hundred
fifty five rupees get the blue ring I
mean oh yeah old school stuff so no more
Zelda's always good when we had to you
had Link's Awakening looks like just an
absolute ball and then just to be like
oh by the way and just like dammit they
understand fanservice they understand
hardcore how to appeal to your hardcore
base in the little things that will get
them excited and that is just again
that's just something that they just
have a gift that that man it's so good
at that
oh Jesus it's ridiculous huh well you
friend that's what you phrase they're
really one of you guys I know in the
podcast I think it's probably you who
phrased it really well it's like they do
they will sell they're gonna sell the
games they're gonna say hey banjos
coming to smash and all these little
things but there's like little touches
and nuance that like the hardcore fans
are gonna like know and they know that's
there somehow see sometimes they feel
out of touch and then sometimes you know
they are just like finger on the pulse
and it's yeah it's weird how they do
both sometimes yeah absolutely yeah so
Zelda was one for me cyberpunks like
everybody's gonna love them and but the
for Bethesda B ghost liar a Tokyo
the lady who announced that though she
became an instant mean because she was
that is like oh you didn't know the late
the short haired like she was really
nervous and knows the fact that she was
like the most candid person who's ever
done a conference because she truly was
just like hey guys I'm nervous and she
was like the creative lead and you know
what she'd done before so everyone was
just like you are amazing we are behind
you like she will sell that game because
she was just truly like she was genuine
yeah and it was like that's cool like
it's not this like hey I'm gonna come
out and say this other stuff for Hoople
or whatever it was just like I'm nervous
but I'm out here in front of like
millions of people online and in front
everybody so she was a thing so that was
just like really really cool as well and
then of course just like Keanu I mean he
broke
oh he broke in there yeah yeah well I
was but it was like it was the best news
I think anybody could get afterwards
you're like hey he's that thing and you
seen her interviews later he is the
second biggest person in that entire
game besides you and you're like holy
like so yeah he is our major you know
huger absolutely I love all three of
those games yet
cyberpunk no breath a while - and yeah
but from but there's the show go Solaria
Tokyo yeah that was my absolute
honorable mention watchdogs Legion I
like what I see and Boober soft so yeah
cuz I thought watchdogs was on the
decline but I have to say oh you shot
the hybrid doom eternal yes it look
fantastic I haven't seen it but yeah
it's good stuff man check out when you
get a chance watched all Legion yeah
definitely height for that three times
only so we are back kind of cut up on
your little history and yeah so while
you were gone I know we had a few guests
come through we were chatting about
stuff last week how much if any have you
even touched this game in a bit this
hurts me to say this week's Road this is
the longest I've gone without playing
destiny and it feels weird
like I've been playing a ton of switch
because I've been traveling right so
switch switch switch switch switch all
day but it's just like it's so weird not
to play and the goal we still these turn
it on and Saturday it'll eat like I
haven't even experienced much of
opulence like I would did Eddie got us a
helmet oh so I got to live through you
and I'm reading the updates and I'm like
always sound fun and the communities
having fun and you know shout out to
check out check out our lords gaming
that net 1 million baby day back over
did shout out the pyro too because
actually I gave him some credit for him
he was one of the first to point it out
- yeah and then it was like I think
houndasaur somebody shouted about - yeah
gotta shout out pyro for checking that
uh Charlie main and then putting that up
without that's huge because it shows the
vibrance in the community shows people
are excited about what they plan on
opulence and we all know what shadow
keep announcement did so
I'm living through you with all the
stuff that we're going to talk about so
before we get to the kind of a little
bit of a gameplay stuff I want to shout
out what Guardian cons-stream is doing
right now yes if you guys have not been
staying tuned to it get in there check
it out I've thrown down a little bit
here and there as well but the biggest
thing is what they're who they're doing
it for it's for st. Jude's there I mean
I've got a small campaign it's all going
to the same cause you guys can see it in
chat same thing click on that link you
guys can donate all it does is just
literally me through Guardian con but
yesterday was the insanity I mean people
have had awesome blocks like Pope in
destiny bikini Cup podcast just going
crazy again we had I know dado dropped
like a big 70 and there's a lot of huge
numbers that have been seeing going on
but right now as of right now what a at
right now two point four five five
million dollars oh absolutely absolutely
awesome what they are doing and if you
guys don't know when kit like if there
was one video advertisement in the first
hour of Bungie stirring go go find that
first hour break and when they play that
video and if you cannot like weep a
little bit oh my god like but a of
because oh it hits you right in the
fields and but it's it's I mean
everything st. Jude's is like travel
expenses like they don't pay for
anything so everything they look like
the average donation is forty three
bucks before st. Jude's so they're not
bigger but that's what they're like they
know they get the big dump but the
average donation so you know how many
little ones come in to knock that
average down to be forty three dollars
Wow so I mean you got the tens the
twenties the little bits they do it
takes thirty two dollars to run that
place for a second mm-hmm thirty-two
dollars per second I think something
like that so it goes fast it goes quick
but I mean yesterday when Bungie like
set it off they had some awesome things
that they were going for so some of the
things they were doing was if you did
$10 he got an emblem if you did $50 you
got a separate emblem $25 I got a chance
to win an item from
the bungee pool a hundred bucks would
get you a chance to win a signed
collector's edition of Destiny 1/2 or
shadow keep one to a par 1 part 1 part 2
or shadow keep just somewhere in that
pool and then they had like different
people playing crucible or gambit or
iron banner and stuff so like $300 would
invert controls for a player and people
just say absolutely lost it 500 would
like all three would rotate 777 people
would like where the Shaq's helmet
thousand dollars which was amazing deeds
would read a lore entry and he had this
like DS for destiny like child's book
for destined it was just absolutely
amazing so they they absolutely they set
goals of up to a hundred and fifty
thousand of which Dylan gets a Destiny
tattoo Wow
they blew that away I don't know if it
was the first hour Alan I don't two
hours it was gone like two hours they
were like 200k easy
so they made new ones they had another
one where Dave Samuels if you haven't
seen it yet Dave Samuels the crazy
animated guy and all divided outcasted
like one match and there's one point in
there he's like a guy goes Blake
illeterate that'd kill him so good and
then Luke Smith came on at a high one
talked about Lord of wolves
he was candid they're gonna kind of
leave it in for iron banner go back up
back I got a stampede
because before I flew out to e3 right
this is a funny little quick funny story
because you know I played like nothing I
just started the quest for opulence
right before I let me play maybe two
hours so I said you know me go straight
to the crucible after I do some of my TV
stuff so I was running with this new
load out of a service revolver Lord of
wolves and I think you know the grenade
launcher baby played the game and I was
beast him like I was beasting so I'm
like okay it was just me you know I'm
just trying out this new loadout now I'm
hurt they come to find out that Lord of
wolves are busted and I really was
what's it oh all this really broken
so what is it about let's break it down
what hurt that you usually had to get a
kill that would activate yeah they in
PvE they're basically would like you'd
kill would activate them people would
like kind of been we'll be unable to
control it and like it'd be that ten
shot like higher power burst what is
like people in PvE or like hey sometimes
I don't want that much right then all
you do is hold reload and the gun lives
in that mode in PvP and it just melts
without getting that the necessary kill
no all you do is hold reload and you
switch which we're all broken like
broken as hell
absolutely Burke oh oh so you just
really you just hold out to bolt it down
and switch and then even switch weapons
switch back it's still there wow the
walls is just you can just turn it on
for the match oh so I got to give myself
credit I don't even know about that
mechanicals you know I'm a crucible
shirt on reference just ultra broken
going into I'm a winner when everybody
is in there it's like okay this is kind
of a thing so everybody's been saying
Murph ignore if it's turned off whatever
mmm-hmm and Luke it just kind of came on
and then shout out to ramshackle shackle
shotgun always literally putting like
transcripts out there of what he said
basically he just said he's like but we
do know Lord of wolves like I'm kind of
trimming this up a little bit it's a
little okay it's like a lot hot it's a
lot spicy on PC it's like a second
sniper rifle mix with a pulse rifle and
you put it in power and Griffin
underneath you you all know what happens
so basically said what they're gonna do
is if you play through this you're gonna
kind of basically get an emblem that's
like I survived
Iron Man's unit for 19 basically it's
like I got a t-shirt type thing but it's
like it you're gonna get an ambulance oh
they're gonna do that there's a patch
coming in July they know they're gonna
adjust it some way but it's just their
way of saying kind of like the fusion
the linear fusion Prometheus live like
laser tag they're like get out there and
use it so shout the Lord of wolves one
of my favorite guns having its moment of
broken girl I never thought Lord of
wolves would be mentioned at all in this
type of context it's hilarious yeah so
it is it's a lot broken right now for
sure
yes I mean they talked about that but
they ended up I mean shout-out to
everybody so far because they started
the stream like goth and Broman bass
that kicked it off with like I think
like 7075 case something bananas they
hit people I think dado hit like 70 he's
gonna be doing tomorrow Saab cosplay in
2020 blessing us has a crazy stream I
think his is tonight that he's got
possible shaving and face get a lot of
crazy stuff actually you know about a
crazy criteria though he is go toe and
then so like I mean they all did for
like just one person being able to put
the stuff up to those guys are doing is
absolutely amazing DCP hit in 70 so I
mean huge chunks got the one I just
checked right now is it 50 and I don't I
kill and don't actually know the guys
the guy who's doing it right now so and
that's just me being kind of out of
touch but like he's at 50 and then
bungee yesterday drops the bomb like the
hundred and fifty K gold for his tattoo
was done in the first hour I think
hybrid said yeah so they set higher
goals they ended up hitting 400 in
literally the last they hit four hundred
thousand like 153 they hit it in the
last minute I actually like got home
after work out with my wife and we
checked it again and it was like last
three minutes four hundred thousand
dollars from them wow this is an
Airstream so so nobody could tell me
anything about this community I'm saying
that's that's one thing this again this
is the reason this podcast even started
right you know because at the end of the
day we both met there and it's just it's
a blessing because you see like-minded
people you see when people give towards
a good cause what can happen and again I
know people gonna say I'm bias that sees
my favorite game but I challenge you to
come up with a community that can mimic
this you know I'm saying it's it's
unbelievable the things you're telling
me and every year they seem to outdo
each other I'll do the last previous
year so and look like they're still
going right they stood still going on
what's going on now yeah it's still
going on and saying like right now it's
basically at like two point four five
six million dollars and it goes through
Sunday and guess who tops this thing off
dr. Lupo is going to be the last one Wow
you know what he can do
because he started in like the Destiny
community he's been having a whole lot
of I mean hats off to that man but his
also fundraising success has been crazy
so between fortnight and the Destiny
community for him to finish it up he is
in a perfect spot to do amazing things
there but you got today it's Co carnage
going on you got Achievement Hunter
after this t-rex this afternoon what's
good games and it's like I'm just not as
close in the twitch community to know
all these people but we're still big
names to go and they're not even done it
is so so impressive though so low
absolute oh yeah
Aries put in check for the before after
a bless that pictures a little fun yo no
crazy
shameless head no beard like clean
shaven makeup eyebrows are gone and
drawn on oh that's like what is it it's
cosmetics and inherit it grows back but
like that picture is $30,000 for for
again st. Jude's like that is absolutely
amazing so yeah Lu slows going for a
million dollars in four hours by the way
those are just massive I can't get mad
no so like I know we're talking about
this for a little while and I know my
voice will probably regret it later but
honestly I don't like just watching all
this is my witnessing everything it's
been so so amazing just even like just
to be around and paying attention to
what's going on is so so cool it's
awesome and it's one of the most
positive things you know destiny and
like I said it's really good to see so
this is great so yeah garden con if you
haven't checked out those streams if you
haven't donated remember it doesn't have
to be a lot every single dollar accounts
so put a dollar in there skip a cup of
coffee throw them five dollars or
whatever it is just just get in one of
those streams I've got the link in chat
for another place to send it that
direction doesn't matter it's all going
to the same place so put some there I'm
gonna just trying to see if like the
people that follow me can if we can do
500 bucks just out of that link just
even 500 bucks just send it that
direction so any and everything yes into
would be amazing um so yeah
Guardian cons going on we are gonna be
at Guardian Con in like two weeks
so what we rather the ryu is like I also
see you in like three years
so in three years yeah cuz was it done
yeah that was regarding cards it was the
one in Tampa one in Tampa mm-hmm yep
yeah so I know because day night you
went one year I didn't go and then I
went one year you didn't go I'm trying
to think if I've even been back I was
about one you went to one and I didn't
go but I think we both skipped last year
maybe yeah cuz I thought about going and
then it just didn't quite happen so
right
I think the only one he's 17 you didn't
go in 2017 no I think that was the only
one I went to cuz I actually want I
remember seeing so yeah about when you
went with me okay mmm mr. Oz he said he
went the last two years
yeah Aries I mean I was at two years ago
I was there two years ago but um that
was that was briefly I do remember that
one the team the ninja and the cheetah
will make up came out wait man long
overdue so I get there Thursday so no
we'll probably like catching up Thursday
night meeting all the people I remember
last time because it was like the night
before the con was that the the wing
place Cosmo stopped by over there I met
Fran and Destin over there some Guardian
con was there so I mean it's like
there's and the next day is like I
pictures with grenadier Jay commits dad
oh I may have like seen fallout and
passing but now I just gotta like by the
man a drink so yeah there's like so many
people I'm looking forward to be and
just like so many people whom destiny
that are going like there's a lot of
them from Bungie sorry not destiny but a
lot from that that are going as well so
it's gonna be amazing out there I
honestly cannot wait and like and mash
set up creeks that like resort out there
is yeah it's um discounted room is gonna
be a steal
did you get your email yet which are
your nice amenities oh god no haven't
even checked
hmmm lot of stuff going on I wonder if
or when you could be off at your goal
get you golf or if you want to mmm
that's gonna be nice yeah that is coming
up oh yeah somehow that went to junk so
mark is no joke yes gotta get make sure
you get the premium things in life that
is enough with Guardian Cod but it is
all so much has come from this community
but started around this game of
amazingness and the game is in a great
spot right now because we've got a lot
of things but on all things even more
Luke Smith when he drops knowledge he
drops important bombs boom and one of
the biggest ones we got to talk about
first and this is the ever verse changes
coming in shadow keep in the fall so
what is one thing that a lot of people
have been asking for sir calc neato
transmog what are we getting in
September sir company no oh man this is
just beautiful this is what I saw this
it just it it hit me in the fields you
know because as you know I am Lord
stylish myself back bar warlock must be
decked out in the finest red so when I
was reading this and if you want me to
start off with it it's just pretty much
you know he was just going on to the
things about ever verse and things that
they've seen and you know it starts off
with armor and he pretty much says that
it you know it stinks to go to every
store and see an item it looks cool and
seeing that that item has bad perks on
it in fact when we send up the armor we
twist ourselves up and knots to make
sure the ever verse armor sets didn't
have the perks and I get that because
they don't want to do like paid and only
be near pay to win and they did yeah to
the police right on time right what I
told here we go salute the men in blue
shield but um yeah man so long he talks
about that you know about ever
Somerset's not having good perks they
did that purposely because they want the
best way to get perks when your armor by
playing the game not shopping for
enhanced hand caning loaders at tests so
basically we get that part so now he
said as of September or ever verse
armour is being converted into universal
ornaments these universal elements can
be applied to all the legendary armor
sets we releasing at fall they override
the look of your equipment while
preserving the perks mods and stats of
the original item any reverse Armour
that you have acquired in your
collections will have its Universal
ornaments automatically unlocked for use
on any new legendary armor for example
if the song in your heart is to have
your Titan role with the 2018 Tin Man
esque festival of the loss helmet you
can put it on any of the legendary armor
coming to the game that's full they show
a nice little graphic showing you the
options showing that armor cosmetic slot
which is huge and then they start
talking about brightness you want to
talk about brightness
sure go for well I mean I was gonna just
touch on that real quick before we jump
down so you've got a couple distinctions
there it does specifically say anything
dropping in the fall so it's gonna be
new drop so what you got now is gonna be
kind of like another shift like from
year 1 or 2 we got on your perk so like
if you want to use the old stuff you can
but if you want to use perks yeah use
the new stuff and leave the stuff in the
past so same thing if you want to have
the cosmetics if you want to look good
you're gonna want to it's fine don't
worry about it it drives me nuts
continue got like major wreck going on
over there it is a way like everybody
always wants to bring stuff forward and
bring stuff forward and we never get
these kind of flake wipes of clean stuff
like I don't want people using midnight
coup and Gjallarhorn for 10 years like
that stuff that gets old and boring as
hell so the fact that this is a new way
for them to make the New Year stuff
distinct mmm and make it make it have
something because you have the new armor
energy Slyke armor 2.0 basically which
we talked about before being like a lot
more customization of perks I don't know
if you're gonna have to unlock them for
the new stuff that whole thing's gonna
be a different animal but then now
you've got the ornaments as well there's
gonna be a lot of incentive on the new
stuff there maybe like hey if you want
to infuse this one enhanced piece up
because it's good until you get
something better you might be doing that
but if you want your
fashion game in check you're probably
gonna be working on there trying to I
really like how they're giving enough
incentive and you use the new stuff and
it's kind of gonna work as a natural
progression of like leaving some of the
old stuff in the past and that's when it
really one is like we need some some
ways to like reset we're gonna have a
lot of new guardians in the game
absolutely new lands gonna be bringing
so people oh oh yeah blueberries in
effect oh I just can't wait to go into
crew Celebi like I feel okay now
yeah did my skill go up or the player
base dressed and we went down minutes
absolutely did you see WD Prescott's
question do you guys think that they
will turn destination armor will become
Universal ornaments as some ways make
these vendors have some kind of purpose
that is one thing I've heard so many
places like the destination vendors need
a purpose again they really so whether
their ornaments whether they get a
refresh set whether even they just get a
similar set that can now drop stuff oror
that can have perk slots on it um
something absolutely something has to
happen yeah we need that man and then
you know what I miss my action yeah no
monarchy Galia man I was feeling so
lowly money they honestly I missed them
shaders I missed me some new monarchy
shade is so badly so you know we'll see
but um yeah I'm hoping that come
September one would hope you know at
least a discussed faction rally when
it's coming back and and and just maybe
to get maybe just start using those NPCs
for the gears or something it would be
nice he'll be nice but definitely
planetary vendors I they definitely need
a purpose for sure something I mean you
got checks you got as of Allah you got
every planetary event or may have a lot
of them now because we have no more
places to go to Aris is probably gonna
be our contact on the moon or a
different person maybe not sure all of
those people just yeah give them a
little life again cuz right now they're
just so the armor from them doesn't even
drop with like perks it's completely
useless so yeah yeah that that needs
to definitely get a little bit of love
somehow somewhat just somebody in a
corner go start like updating their
stuff you got you got some time yeah so
but yeah just I'm also liking the
hopeful progression of pushing people
into kind of working on new stuff I mean
coming from my world of warcraft
background you got a new expansion you
left have new brought nothing forward
cuz all the new stuff was better it was
a higher level or whatever so it would
be interesting I know they're doing
Armour 2.0 it looks like the little
infusion thing is on there I'm hoping
they address some type of currency with
that because that's one thing my brother
hates is always like you know infusion
cores and stuff like that and it's the
train smog will help in picking your
perks will also help on some of that
because if like hey I got a new arm
interrupt but I just go in and dial in
the perks that I want that still gives
you a little more of like okay at least
as I'm progressing I can still have the
same functionality yes out so however
that armor 2.0 hopefully will help the
need for infusion because if I get a new
chest piece and it looks different it
may not be like quite the one I want but
if I can have that same function of like
oh I want my machine gun loader and
machine gun scavenger and that's just
the two I've got all they're like dude
like then I don't have to worry about
infusion then gore's could go back to
more of like the Master Dan purpose or
unlocking later like yes they should be
master work course they should be
enhancer they're not enhancing anything
when you infuse they're just like
equalizing your value so no that's the
other piece that I want to see get some
type of adjustment but absolutely yeah
like this is huge transmog is something
people are waiting on and it gives like
Paul testy said he's like I've been
asking for this for so long he's been on
it for a minute and he's been already
had that suspicion that like the perks
were he's like they're kind of trashy
and he honestly had the hunch that they
actually were trashy to make sure it
wasn't Pater when he had that Norton a
little article cuz like they wanted to
avoid it and it's just like like it like
sidearm reserves and auto rifle room
like what crap trashes this and they
know it and they're way to kind of like
it's a skin yeah and they because at the
end of the date I was you know doing the
Activision days and you know the latter
still my boy but that's you know they're
the last thing they want it is be like
oh just go to the store and you know be
some pay-to-win
mechanic will you get the best gear with
the perks and stuff like that so I
understood this enemy back then i
understood that what the way i mean it
sucked because the gear looks so good
but then like luke Smurf said you're
getting like I can't wear it because
look how ineffective I would be as a
Guardian comparison to what I have so
yeah I put article up on this as well
Lord's giving that man and my take on it
was literally like this no longer
restricts us you know I'm saying but we
have to admit the fashion aspect of of
Destiny is it strength like these cool
armor sets these ornate kind of look
good - yeah absolutely in these artists
man yeah fantastic so it's good to be
able to do it I'm super excited for like
this one out is like wow really
okay huge huge big news yeah so that is
one half what happened yes yes and then
the other half is evolving bright best
so basically they said the best way to
earn brightness previously has been if
you get your packages or you buy some
stuff with silver and you break it down
and they're like well that kind of sucks
mmm so they're changing out so a couple
things to note changes to dismantling of
reverse items and one thing to note for
everybody playing right now get rid of
everything that is bright dust based go
shows and shaders ever verse armor in
your vault ships get rid of all break
all that stuff down accumulate as much
brightness as you can before September
17th
because when shadow keep launches that
stuff will not do that anymore it will
break down into shards and glimmer which
is what you're gonna use to buy that
stuff back now which is shards easy to
shards and glimmer easy and stuff to get
but bright dust will not be involved now
bright dust you'll still be able to earn
and they said they're changing how
you're gonna earn that okay so it's
gonna be involved in playlists basically
with regards to stuff like night falls
and strikes and gambit and crucible I
think it's the bounties as what they
have set up right now and I don't know
if they'll change stuff later right now
mostly they're saying the bounties are
gonna be what you're gonna use to earn
break
best ok so just doing your daily
crucibles daily gambit daily strike
bounties whatever it is basically just
playing the game
yeah so mm-hmm nice like there's times
when I get enough of the cosmetic
engrams like I've got 30,000 bright
ghosts right now so I'm okay on that
front your 5 seem to be ok yep they're
like but they're like take the time
break everything down get rid of every
damn shader get rid of all that stuff so
you when you you have as much as you can
brighten us going into shadow keep when
that transition happens exam but just
there also this fall they're changing
brightness from pay slash and or pay to
earn currency to a play to earn reward
they want you to just basically play the
game in you know get it as you're going
through and then this like these two
things I think are hugely telling to
Bungie being independent yes like this
is some of the biggest like some of the
stuff like shadow keep the free to play
like new light is amazing all the stuff
but then these types of changes to have
a verse like ever verse armor sets the
other ornaments mm-hmm and now you're
like hey I want to spend six bucks on a
set of armor or ten bucks on a set of
armor but I know I can use that crap
everywhere like he that would have
worked better during Activision now I
don't know if it's something they
couldn't do or it was a different
decision choice there was a marketing
thing somewhere or if it's just they had
this you know new epiphany of like this
would work better but whatever the
choices are I don't care like this is
like the all these things coming like
shadow keeps sounding cool armor 2.0
artifacts I don't even understand yet I
still want to know more about those
we've gotten these changes come in the
new light like the free-to-play players
are gonna be all nice so we need and
also you're looking to have some nice
fresh meat out there so oh yeah slide
them up light em up but so many things
we keep seeing like Luke Smith being
more active and talking like bunch are
you truly being part of guardian Connor
I don't even know if they can magically
ministering that's a good point
that's a very good point that
independence has to accommodate
something like that
yeah you you sense it in the energy but
we sensed it when we watch the shadow
shadow keep stream I mean they just felt
free they were just you know envisioning
destiny in their own vision way they
want to do and especially when he came
out with the exclusivity thing and he's
like look we got put away with all that
stuff
everyone's gonna play to get like cool
stuff you see the shift internally yeah
it's been really really cool like the
amount of people going to Guardian con
to like all so so so cool insane
like I know a couple of people on PC
that are going I know there's like half
the half of the stream team yesterday
who was on there I can see it guarding
cantos he already comes here guarding
kind of like I just need to like take
him like my old destiny one package and
half start plate I want people to start
signing these things like I know there's
like 600 so it's not half the crew is
gonna be there now one other thing that
Luke said yesterday that I wanted to
point out is when he talked about Lord
of wolves yes the reason they're waiting
mm-hmm is because he's like due to the
raid release and the contest modifier
and the times that it came out we just
had some guys go through like kind of a
mini crunch for that okay and he's like
we could get something for Lord of
wolves potentially out quicker but I
don't want to do that to them right now
so it's gonna be a little bit later and
that is one of the best things I think
I've ever heard out of them to be like
right now we're gonna take care of them
Lord of wolves we know it's gonna come
in a little later patch we're not gonna
go kill our employees right now because
we want that balance too and that is
like something you don't see or hear
that often and now it's over so cool so
but that's also one of those pieces like
when we're sitting there talking about
hey how many resources did they have or
stuff like that that's one of those
things to remember is like whatever
small team if they're gonna go crunch
and push out the raid or if this like if
there's gonna be a crunch to fix Lord of
wolves just remember that when we're
talking about the resources of like how
much content they can put into anything
if something like that can take a little
extra push right so is like they they
are independent but they don't have just
like hey can you guys do this or this
other studio or do we have any
we can pull their their own and they
have to figure out that balance so this
the cadence the amount of content like I
don't expect shadow keep to like let me
down by any means but like just going
forward beyond that mmm people do have
to temper how much we can get because
when they limit it for something like
Lord of wolves we just have to like
everybody has to know like if flukes
miss like hey we're gonna push this
thing back a month just because we don't
want to kill her employees and like one
week or gave them the next four weeks
they will let them spend some time with
her family and we'll see it a month
later like those types of things I am
100% behind because that's for the good
of the company and that will keep that
company what it is so scientists think
he's slick right now but I won't let him
rot like I slid this party with this
baby
howdy letting people not cry I was cute
I like that I like that let you rock
I'll let you revelry all I will say is
with a company's like this that's very
good to see and I think in their case it
comes down to priorities I think they
have a structure and the structure is
yes they could do more the Wolves you
know but it would pull them away from
something else and let's be honest
shadow keep is big for them because we
didn't anticipate anything really this
September especially with the
competition this September and I just
want oh my god roar save to work
smoothly so in this case push my little
L owb let them run free for a little bit
just make sure that come September
everyone can do what they want to do and
also the big thing is transitioning from
most likely battlenet now to steam let's
see how that's gonna go so like I said I
stitch doing I see you doing we got we
go we gonna allow this to happen to ya I
don't know what you're talking about
just up old little rivalry points later
I mean I know we talked about that
though but just the fact that they do
want to take care their employees that's
a great yeah see and it just makes it a
little more we
you're like hey don't spend the six
bucks in the other verse and like help
like and support Bungie yeah yeah that's
one of those things but it makes it
easier to be like do I want to cuz I've
spent a little bit here and there but if
there's more like I might be a little
more care for you during the seasons if
I'm like yeah straight in their pocket
yep I'm with the new storage is so more
inviting almost like a direct body what
you want and then it's like it's like a
real Oh this was it you know this is
coming through you know you can get here
once it's just I love the new approach
to ever verse and you know I'll be
honest like I'll be the first on reset
I'm going to ever like that's part of my
routine I need to see what ornaments
she's got was going on like that's a big
part of us so I have no problem I'll be
the first to tell you like it's not
pay2win it's just like I'm paying
cosmetics to support a game I love and I
want them to flourish I want them to do
well and it all it is it's constant
let's be real these artists are
fantastic so support or good mm-hmm
so yeah those two big things like
community says TLDR all ever verse armor
nu and armor you've already acquired as
being converted into Universal ornaments
universe ornaments can be attached to
any newly acquired legendary gear
brighten doesn't is gonna come from
doing bounties not dismantling things
you spent money on Everest items can now
be pulled from your collections with
glimmer and legendary stars instead of
bright dust before September 17th
dismantle all of your unused diverse
items to maximize your brightest
reserves period so that's a nice way to
wrap it up and Luke Smith like seeing
his name at the bottom you're like oh oh
okay mmm like when he says things people
listen and they matter so it's been
really really cool um so yeah this week
we've got iron banner going on whoo as a
band has the low:11 I that's a little
here and there but I didn't see just
like everyone running with it
I don't like universally accepted like
there's some people that are gonna use
it but like some of the quest actually
makes you not anyway much did you go
through how's it looking out deal with
salad ball so far the quest is well
first off swarm of the
Ravin if i'm remembering that damn name
right it's a grenade launcher hold on
gotta find it oh yeah yeah yeah I think
use his brain caramel so mother Raven
can we talk about grenade kills we'll
get to that
oh yeah I was about to say what's
Prescott talk about so mmm-hmm
first off before you actually make
progress on the quest if you have
leftover tokens and you don't have a
swarm of the Raven grenade launcher
yeah with spiked grenades try and get
one because then as soon as you open up
the loop pool and do the quest steps you
open up armor to be in that loop pool so
the drops are in there more I mean halo
bear says iron banner has been Lord of
wolves fast so I think it just kind of
depends I've seen it some I just haven't
seen it played like you know five on
five or something like that so but swarm
of the Raven is basically the best DPS
thing with someone using tractor cannon
against the new raid boss mm-hmm so that
is why it's the 150mm
so it's the fastest grenade launcher
it's Lloyd it's got spiked grenades so
it's gonna get that extra direct hit
damage and if you just jump it into a
giant head of a boss here comes a lot of
damage and that is a complete the
highest dps thing because one personal
do to hit the extra void Luna well just
do two and nothing and it beats
everything everything right now so
there's a graphic out there can't even
remember the names yeah it beats like
anarchy and mountains up and out bruh it
beats them all so Wow now the other
option if you did start the quest don't
worry if you have another character to
finish the quest on one characters play
as much as you want and then with your
tokens on a different character just buy
it all just viola dice so it's already
part of it that's yeah halos like the
ideal would be hard lunch spiked
grenades and filled prep for those extra
reserves and my broken vault or I've got
everything to the gills gosh yeah you
yeah I've got grenade perks got
everything well I don't have everything
down sir Oh believe me that's forever
but I will say right now my occasional
games when I'm running more snipers yeah
pulled out my reverie downhill with
enhanced sniper rifle targeting got
let's with sniper rifle loader and
scavenger pulling on a chess piece with
enhanced unflinching sniper mmm
ya know it's like God armor all yeah cuz
I kept everything justified is hard yeah
I got I got a little bit cuz man it's a
pain in the butt my mold I'm dead I
actually have I'm 477 to 500 right now I
actually got a little I got a I got like
enough tape let's I take a little baby
breath I'm like oh my lord
so your ridiculous mom made the hoarder
awesome yep Luke said to break the
members of our stuff down that we go and
break the everything they already got
most of that stuff done boy
I mean exotic ship sparrows and ghost
those aren't taking up vault space but I
can still break them down shaders break
them all down you don't need them and
all that stuff so but yeah I'm up to
seven forty nine point six on one of my
characters the other two have been a
little less focused but even just moving
the weapons over the warlock 734 107 22
so if I play on them they'll come up but
right now the Titans been the focus
that's where I've spent most of my time
mmm so what else we got
yeah the iron banner quest has some
steps I haven't seen them all and others
one is just like killing Guardians
another one is capturing zones and then
the third one I don't know if I got to
it yet because I didn't I know there's
one reach I have to use like scout rifle
swords fusion rifles auto run auto
rifles like literally all the stuff no
one wants to use why you are like
literally forced to use it now kills
wise like how's it looking at his
lengthy is it like like a no not slow
I mean no it is kind of slow progress
like capturing points I was looking down
as like wasn't a lot like I ended up
getting it after playing quite a few
matches but focus more on the points and
the more people in there is better like
if you're playing with a group and
you're like hey everybody on point
school like everybody over here as many
okay cool like you could probably get
some stuff done faster but it's like
Brooks the season-long quest
some people want to burn through an
entire quest in a wheel and no like I
don't have enough time well you'll have
more iron banners so it's meant to be a
full season long thing just some people
are treating it that way but it is it's
gonna be a longer grind it's not one
you're like hey can I do this on
Saturday maybe if you play all day yeah
you really got to put that commitment
yeah and all it does is unlock the armor
but the armor drops at max level or at
not max at powerful gear level you still
have the seven bounties that are gonna
drop powerful gear so between the seven
and the five drops you'll get four armor
that's 12 drops just from playing iron
banner if you finish the whole thing but
if not the bounties which I mean I'll
get those probably like today or
tomorrow the bounties you still can do
those and that's gonna give you a big
boost so yeah I mean if you're looking
to level up play some iron banner get
some stuff in there yeah it opens up if
you're looking for a grenade launcher
for the raid swarm of the ravens spike
grenades is great as they roll honestly
even if you've gotten edged transit with
spike grenades it's still thinking of
there because it's void grenades the
size my grenades and the void with
tracker cannon is tractor cannons easy
to get the buff on and then just dump in
damage in Oulu no rift and you're good
to go
so yeah I mean the mechanics still have
to get done but for bossed up damaged
yeah that's pretty solid alright I gotta
check this out yep so truth is out in
the wild mm-hmm that quest launched last
week while you were out basically yes so
my boy and tear you got a hilarious
troop video out of you got a chance to
see it absolutely allowed you have to
check that out of it
each other - over there gonna run into
them I don't know if ice I'm trying to
think of I watched a few of those I'm
trying to think if I saw his I saw the
gif on Twitter
he's like it's locked on and they can't
see anything and then they just move up
and shoot it goes mmm like boom two
seconds later yeah it's like it's it's
it's got it came back how it had two
three in the chamber and that's an
amazing tracking like it's it came back
right so if it was gonna be like one of
the chamber or not aggressive tracking
it's like it came back right and it's
like all right it's it oh my god in
gambit though I've been hit by that so
many times as an invader it's rough
really it's tracking a solid and they
just like look dear you throw it up in
the sky and it'll do a big-ass art to
get to you Dan you got your grenade and
horseshoes against Odin in that minute
yeah it's beast yeah it's rough so that
one's hard to dodge and then I dodged
one the other day behind a wall and a
dude snuck me in the side of that hahaha
salute yeah so truth is definitely one
you don't want to skip on cool little
quest not bad some interesting pieces to
it menagerie we got a new boss this week
which actually haven't been in - I need
to get in there so I know it's a new
boss so this is the 3 week rotation and
then next week we see heroic mode so on
heroic mode we've got a couple new
changes so right now I'm an Aries
match-made and I've really enjoyed how
it's like no fail mode you'll eventually
get through it by time like there's no
wiping mechanic throw all that stuff out
the window for Roy so we've got
matchmaking disabled mmm extinct
extinguishes active if you wipe its back
to orbit old school nightfall mow all
school knife or idea what encounters
never repeat if you like trick like do a
little bit on each encounter and don't
have that bar at a hundred percent
before you finish you're done you don't
even get to see the boss so you got to
fill that bar before you see each
encounter once so I don't know if
there's like six or seven but that's all
you get
there's gonna be weekly curated game
modifiers rotating per boss power
difficulty starts at 750 goes to 770 mmm
Wow that's the artificial difficulty
piece I'm always kind of like I kind of
hate that
but that kind of sounds like the
20-point power gap the head for the raid
so that's like sound like kind of what
they're feeling on I get it but yeah
it's like six player no matchmaking
extinguishes active if you don't reach
the boss you're kicked out 770 power and
you can you max at 750 so you're gonna
be fighting above your paygrade
so mmm all of that information what are
your thoughts on the uh what do you
think it rocks this may sounds cool man
it sounds like like you know it took me
it hawkins me back to like the days of
the challenge mode you know the same and
i like that aspect i love what you
talking about in reference that knife
all kind of mechanic with you you guys
fail you're going back to orbit like it
adds that different layer of difficulty
i think that's cool i think the event
itself sounds who I cannot wait still to
get my head chopped it because I was so
busy but my knowledge it definitely
sounds great and I'm liking this variety
I'm liking the things that I'm hearing
so far so good stuff good stuff sorry
alright so yeah that's gonna be rough so
if you're not at 750 get there yeah I
gotta get cracking anyone below 750 will
have swords and below 740 will have
skulls yeah so 750 is literally you're
gonna have to be maxed to go do that and
honestly with no fail mode finding a
fireteam you're gonna want to be anyway
yeah the big thing so you haven't
touched menagerie yet oh I have not even
stepped foot I just saw like it was step
on a little little barge and saw
Benedict didn't we you have me doing
stuff that's literally as much as I play
well that's how Warner by the way oh
sorry look like a little Benedict to me
yeah dad Benedict's brother
when you find time but it's like you had
ether in so much other stuff it's okay
um sort of this the plan is Saturday
just at least it throw it on get my feet
wet with a little bit things start
getting back into the grind to getting
given to the mix there a little bit miss
it but yeah so it's gonna be it sounds
like it's gonna be
I mean you've got yeah this is the first
time we've had like a heroic or a hard
difficulty coming back since basically
Leviathan so they kind of threw most of
that out the window for a while there's
them in hardline Jewish right hard
anything so this is them thinking about
bringing back the difficulty cuz even
indeed one we had normal and hard like
that was part of the raids in King's
ball being developed around hard and
then being normal then you saw it gets a
hardened it was like it was what
developed around that I would love for
them to get back to some of that stuff
like the normal brain difficulty where
you could have like maybe some you know
not my even matchmaking in there but
maybe a little bit or a little looser
guy to games or something on normal so
the mechanics aren't quite as crazy but
then the hard mode is where you get the
really top stuff like those are kind of
things now there is one thing mm-hmm
when you think about heroic so right now
when you do the menagerie if your
chalice is upgraded you can pick to get
an Austrian or hand cannon with a range
role and with a range master work and
then you're just going for perks you
just waffle percocet and some people are
getting like outlaw rampage with range
master work on a damn good basically aya
saloon and people like okay so the big
question is what do you think you can
get from heroic and do you think the
rewards are gonna be worth it what would
one would hope that you know they're
implementing ammo that they would take
you back to the days of you know like I
said big-time challenge most big-time
raid if I remember back in the day we
used to play it's a taken King and you
know you'd get that second version of it
you know like the the full armor set and
stuff like that whether it be a
collaboration or baby a couple extra
person that's specific to you know the
event so what I'm hoping for is that
kind of variety and you know just
something introduced something new I
mean who doesn't want any additional
weapons or any additional gear that kind
of stuff so it'll be interesting to see
how to handle it but um yeah I agree
get that in there you know say just for
just a reward that extra difficulty mean
this stuff doesn't sound like it's the
easy I mean dudes are come up with
strategy but again in the beginning
getting bumped to orbit and stuff like
that just adding that
really should be roar'd would you think
that's I mean that's kind of crucial
it's like it's kind of like putting a
hard mode of a raid in there and you
don't get anything from it's the same
thing you have to incentive five people
to want to go into log2 want to try this
pain-in-the-butt thing to get kicked or
risk getting kicked out cuz if you're
just going in there for mostly triumphs
and you get the same rolls out of your
chalice that's not gonna incentivize a
lot of people to go in there so you have
to have that incentive and heroic I mean
I would like just be floored if I saw it
but it would be a really good thing
adept versions or onion-like specific
curated perks like wow you took a so I
mean though like that type of level
needs to be there because there needs to
be something for that extra brutal
challenge because even like extinguish
isn't even gonna be on the damn raid
yeah and you've got like like this is
gonna be rough I mean if you play
through some of those encounters now
some are okay I can see like they're
running around being like the running
around encounter you hit the little
beams of light or hold down the plates
and stuff like that like you're gonna
need to strategize in like the tracker
cannons and they swarm of the Raven
grenade launchers like those are gonna
be probably really helpful in there too
so those are gonna be big but on top of
that you've got just plate so so much
like pain to go through it has to be
worth it in some way like curate it
almost doesn't sound like enough
honestly doubt about that yeah I think
Prescott said it like repost which is
the so there's Knights like the Knights
with shields that like walk around with
them what Captain America walk at night
walking on with the shield from evil
times those are the ones who will drop
like the hive sword and then those are
the ones you have to smash constantly to
get to break the like bubble shield on
some of the enemies as you work through
also in one of the encounters like that
thing has already got like curse troll
and acolytes going around in there and
then it escalates to ogres and you got
an ogre boss who's gonna smash or shoot
you like it's already gonna be just
bonkers and probably odd like you're
gonna feel like you're just ultra
squishy anyway you get a full team wipe
they're cool you're out like you just
kicked orbit like and
certain ones in there where I've seen
just those are not the biggest of rooms
there's a lot of crap going on and I
don't know it's gonna be a whole like
six warlocks I swear I mean you're gonna
need a couple continually rotating like
Phoenix Protocol Luna faction Wells are
gonna be crucial
heather's they're gonna be big I mean
you gotta take like built teams like in
a raid I mean the triumphs are gonna be
a thing I don't know how bad those are
gonna be to get but oh my god riposte
with blackout Chad go did a report but
that's just it that's one of those to me
where this brings up a completely good
example is the Shrieker laser beam oh my
god all of those things I can picture
just being absolute hell like if you
have a void modifier you may as well
just kiss your butt goodbye for a week
like seriously if it's void and back out
I'm done guys that is one of those
things for me actually when it comes to
the fall that I want I want new
modifiers in activities because we've
been on the same crap for a tonne of
lawyers yeah good point absolutely I
mean give me like small arms and
specialists and make some new crap up
mmm like I don't
it doesn't always just have to be like
Malee's grenades and Blake
what's the other one I don't even
remember but it's like you've got melees
grenades and heavy but I was like what
about specialist of and snipers hit for
like 200,000 for fun like if you're like
okay I'm gonna pull avoid sniper because
it's a void we can you can have a blast
like your small arms may not do that
much but if I'm blowing heads off with a
sniper rifle it feels good oh absolutely
feels good but that's one of those
things like reckoning is bro I don't win
it was some hearing things
I'm hearing things well like reckoning
is like I didn't ever want to touch it
on certain modifier days and when
certain days do that to you it really
isn't great for your activity you have
to watch that
I mean glass is one of those in there
you're sitting on it's how are your like
there is not a way to survive that when
you have half the health because you're
already squishy enough with snipers in
degree angle and smashes in 6002 role so
it's like they had to adjust modifiers
there and take it out and like same
thing if you put glass or like the one
we have to run around and pick up the
health orbs it's like I'm just trying to
be on the ground floating and moving
just to try and keep a little bit of
health I have if I have to go try and
get to an orb to get that back like so
the modifiers I know people will be able
to do it not a question like the great
good teams are going to but it's like
the like if I'm gonna ask like hey
Prescott and bender and like the guys
that I have in my discord like if you
guys want to go in there and we go in
and it's just like it just doesn't come
together it's defeating quit that's the
fifth of progress can't get made and
it's gonna be really like extinguish oh
yeah
start it over start it over and it's
gonna be rough no I am very curious to
see how it goes because there's gonna be
some crazy difficulty spikes I think
that people aren't expecting because
they haven't they haven't failed it yet
they haven't experienced failure I know
and they're like oh I'll do this now
and then on top of that the rewards if
they're not worth it it's gonna shoot it
in the foot people just don't do normal
there won't be a reason so the tribe
hunters will want the ones going for
shadow which is a one of the coolest
titles by the way mm-hmm you have I was
like that fits you you're like the ninja
the shadow yeah I kind of have to go for
that one's got a guy gotta go for that
way yes that's me nope so it's it's
gonna be a pain in the ass title to get
scuse my language but it is gonna be a
rough so I'm gonna take a little break
here for just a second guys I'm just
gonna read an ad real quick pay some
bills keep this thing supported and we
will be right back and we're back thank
you guys for taking that little break
with us but yeah just kind of wrapping
up this discussion on the heroic
menagerie mode I mean is there any major
things that like we haven't discussed is
there any things you want to see there
are potentially some catalysts who are
gonna see it that like is my very
catalyst from that mm-hmm like wow what
do you think that's like from what I
heard on his own August burden is that's
not gonna take like the full force Dec
for the full damage mmm
so what you think that what you think
they might do because you yeah that's
what you have you do to get the highest
or DPS maybe three
mm-hmm maybe if it just does that maybe
economy yeah maybe economy damn cuz I
don't think I don't know if you can I
mean boosting the damage higher in PVE
would be cool but PVPA what's not gonna
matter but animal economy being able to
get to that sooner if you get one pick
up if you start with two and you get
that one pick up with even scavenger or
whatever yeah you can do it but you
might have something left over to so I
think yeah my guess is economy I feel
like there's some data mind stuff out
there but that's just a guess
and there's other ones like that that
are supposedly coming but we haven't
seen a whole lot of new Catholic I've
seen a lot yeah we've been waiting to be
pilots for a minute man yep so menagerie
is gonna unlock some things I know all
the craziness is gonna happen next week
I've got one character that's close to
ready but man I don't know if I've got
like the patience to work my way through
and we will see and then the week after
two days before we head off to Guardian
con because I would literally be flying
on 4th of July Luana is gonna lunch now
truth was the Annual Pass quest actually
me because that got confirmed and I said
another quest was gonna be for everybody
so Lumina potentially is gonna be the
one for everybody this time do you do
you agree with that switch which would
you rather have for everyone I'm
different I mean what about you I mean I
mean the way it's gone like last word
thorn and lumen I figured that would be
the Annual Pass one just because they
have been in that trend right cuz it's
been like the annual passes like hey
this is a cool quest line this is a cool
quest line and truth wasn't bad but I'd
make sure Lumina being like if it's
related to Thor if it's really it's
really crazy Laura stuff like that would
be the one again it's cool they might
give it to everybody but again it's like
the one that seems like it would have
fit in in your past to go with
everything else we've seen so yeah no I
agree okay I definitely want to see
outta here big-time big-time because
obviously we know the connection with
the guns are stuff like that I will say
I like last words acquisition questions
guys except the end was a little you
know bang bang bang I liked it it was
broken but I mean I did like I liked
that it fit the flavor of the weapon and
it just you know I'm saying
added to that lawsuit you just hope the
lumina we learn more about this dark
twisted history with thorn and then
where it's wrong what this is stuff like
that I love learning stuff like that in
context with it yeah
if you dig through the lore the stories
in this game man there's a lot out there
it's just they have so much on screen
and stuff like that to do so that comes
on the second will be at Guardian cone I
giveback Tuesday so that's no skin to be
a little delayed the that's the ninth
that Tuesday we get the tribute hall and
moments of triumph
mm-hmm so we know moments of triumph is
all about the t-shirt what have you done
for the past year this has been an
insane year because the first year was
like we had Leviathan yes okay then the
other thing this year we had forsaken
last wish black Armory scourge of the
past we had the like two quests with The
Drifter all of those invitations in the
nine like the moments of triumph could
be one hell of a list depending on how
much you have to do to go yeah yeah they
could be asking a lot so we got a year
we got to see how this thing's gonna
roll out yeah so that and the tribute
hall I don't I don't know what that is
it's it's got to be a location little
violin but I don't know if it's like go
to the tribute hall and it was like
check your accomplishments but I'm not
gonna go up and like read about ebon
tisana statue or is it like you go up
here and this is like this is the rain
statue I'm like I don't know what the
tribute hall I don't picture it being
like an activity is it just like a new
social space kind of like dog I don't
know what it I cannot figure out my head
what the hell that is do you have any
idea listen I have no idea but one thing
I do know is I remember our quick that's
what I remember so just good like okay
you know what sounds cool
let's see cuz you know my mind still
annual pass but look Ibanez has been
great right we can't so far so good song
as ROM start you know saying ready nice
and now menagerie people getting in
their mix we got quests we got new stuff
coming so you know
just wanna see I want to see but I mean
you know I'm just gonna know that's like
expectations the bottom out of that are
speculate like I wish I could go back
would go back to that I was so much no
we were like we're just like it could be
like heartburn everywhere in raids like
different bounties it was one bounty it
wasn't even special II didn't even put a
new icon it was Billy
hey buddy at the end this was changed to
art I'm like wow and that is one of
those like communication pieces they
have they can't do that crap again like
if you put anything on we still
acknowledging art no it's not an
earthquake it was a patch it was a patch
that feather was a bad joke and you got
some cool emotes all it was yeah that
was probably one of the biggest
disappointments of the entire year I
would probably say like just because you
had just even like throwing modifiers
and I know it maybe not be the easiest
thing to do but like they've done snow
balls before and strikes like you could
do something like what if there were
little arc balls instead that had a
little like lightning when you throw
them or anything anything could have
been there so July nights may not be
that big of a deal but it will be
something moments of triumph will
definitely be some stuff to work on
though so we'll see when that list is
like but tribute hall honestly it may
just be a social space the locker I'm
gonna be like this is cool yeah I have
no idea - and then finally that'll give
some time so it's July 9th and then the
next thing we've got basically this is
gonna be kind of that little lower piece
to just kind of see what's coming next
is July 30th the sauces of Heroes that's
gonna be last time we had the re I don't
even remember what they were called the
read read read on missions Redux maybe
yeah yeah so we had the Redux missions
maybe they'll do a few more of those for
like what we've seen in the past like
old stories are different like story
campaigns and things like that so we
might have some readings missions again
crazy grind if you want the armor in the
ornaments the ornaments better hold on
but that's a little July 30th and that
is it on that calendar until September
17th sled is six weeks yeah I said wow
that's a WoW
if you drive apart now if you knock some
stuff off your list you might might have
yourself a little downtime to breathe
away from destiny and then just kind of
get ready to ramp up for ya the world of
shadow keep so what you like do you feel
I mean this season is I mean in this
first month we're gonna basically get it
all in the July seconds the last quest
and obviously expect expectations are in
the bottom for that tribute hall that's
like one two three four or five weeks
you are and then you're basically you've
seen the season and then you've got
nearly two months until we get two and a
half months until we get shadow keep
mm-hmm so do you do you I know you have
a touch the season that much but in
comparison to like I mean you had the
forges that came out and they were like
trickled we've talked about it could
have been better
you had drifter which is if you love
gambit you had fun if you didn't the
invitations were like the invitations
were like yeah but they were like they
were well it was just like there was
like one said there's another it's at
the end of course it was so there were
only two cinematics and then everything
else was like you had the allegiance
quest which had you know some little
changes and tweaks to it but it was like
some of that stuff was thinner and
spread this one was like as you were
kind of going for a little more
front-loaded a little like like you know
new activity front-loaded had the raid
and then you got a breather so which of
I mean for this season I think everybody
loves her right now but it's like based
on the activities but if it took like if
it was a different season and they had
you know they did the raid and then you
know they did like the iron banner quest
and then they did the Lumina quest and
then they dropped Menagerie boss and
then they did the truth quest and then
they did another minute if they spread
this one out more
would you have but it's still content
like a lot of people are really enjoying
would you have enjoyed the spread like
that and that's the thing it's like
drifter was like a bluff for a lot of
people because of the content Forge was
like the same forges over like as they
have a good mix of things would the
spread be better or do you still like
the front load like just for this season
like I know the other ones like people
have issues but if you take saw
stuff that we've seen people are
enjoying the audience's their pinnacles
unfortunately have been lower this
season but like how do you feel about
the spread first front-load is what I'm
getting at basically um the opulence
right now see bucking the trend so to
speak right it seems to be again it's a
it's still early we still have to play
this thing out and then remember after
July 30th you know that's you know we
got to see what's going on cuz that
that's gonna be a big gap but um you
know shout out to help a reference to
things with the invitation but um look
it's all about compelling content if you
have compelling content you are afforded
gaps you are afforded things because
people are really engrossed in the
content you know what I struggle with
sometimes is just like you know the time
gain sometimes and you know I was still
gonna print excise back saying I'm just
gonna give them away you're gonna have
to earn them in some fashion you know
means so you know again the first two
showed no I wasn't really a fan yeah I'm
saying opulence is kind of like saying
hey it can be done but it got it has to
be done right has to be compelling
content and then also in opulence the
you know in fairness to the drifter
drifter didn't have a raid know season
treated right so and this seems to be a
solid one I'm not gonna say oh my god
but it's solid at least the vibe I'm
seeing it's in the mix of people
enjoying it's not like the dumpster fire
of spire of spiritless fire exactly it's
not no one ever just like oh my god I'm
tired of throwing balls and all the
mechanics like five minutes of just like
if you miss one ball then you're like
you can't do damage there versus just
like scourge which is like shoot the
guys the shotguns drive shoot the big
guy like it's and there's a balance in
there as you said so here's like when
you think about next year obviously
shadow keep is going to be its own
season of life but that's like the new
launch then you have potentially three
other seasons we don't know it's three
months four months cadence whatever if
it is like burrito
so a lot of people want trials if they
did something like a
EVP season how do you think that would
be received mm because there's a lot of
people that want trials and if they hype
it up and they launch it be like new
trials maps and like new but and they're
like and that's the whole focus of a
season people there's a lot of it
there's some of the community that would
love that and then there's people that
my brother would be like I'm just gonna
set it down for three months because he
doesn't like right I thought about so
but it's like but also like that would
be some of the fanservice moment to the
people who felt like they got neglected
for years so where do you think that
would fall or do you think that's just
like do you think they can put trials on
a calendar slot or do you think it
deserves a season where do you where do
you feel I know that's like six
questions unpack all that you're like
let me start talking now I mean it's a
touchy situation cuz as much as I love
crucible the thing comes down to like um
they have they are not convinced that
it's in the place it needs to be so they
have to bring it back in first the way
they want it second when you look at the
population as much as I don't like you
know it's still a PvE kind of strong
dominant kind of online population so I
think they're in a better position to
bring it back post shadow keep because
of the cross save and the online
population now coming up with all the
congregation I think that's our best
shot
um I would hope shadow keep we see it
but my gut tells me is gonna be a lot
going on with that
you know maybe Aris I mean it would be
the ultimate cherry on a Sunday right
but really I'm gonna pull it abates
realistically oh it's not come on shadow
keepers yeah yeah I don't see it so no
it's gonna have to be one of those later
seasons not yet your second question is
like as far as how they divvy it up if
they do annual pass again for like you
know from market deserves like a season
or do you think it's like well they if
it's like this is the July 11th on the
calendar trials goes live like I would
like a season I just worry though it
would be the opposite way it would be
all about me I'm like feces
you're like I live it in there and
everybody
like better doing missions err why would
he play exactly I would recognize that
the rest of the community would not be
it would be like least I think drifters
that happy balance right the gambit
you know not everybody likes you look
live invasion your ears are gonna write
back for me you know that kind of thing
so I think it has to come as a separate
mole I don't think they can revolve a
season around unless they have PvE
content cyrus comes back and um you know
they you know they do something you know
shut up boy yeah like inactivity he
needs to come back y'all we miss him we
miss him this is the best warlock in the
game but the real talk though I mean it
would be nice to have you know a PvP
kind of event but they still need a
balance of some PvE stuff if I if it
gonna come back my new guest now is
probably like that March that spring
ikana
area 2020 of the this would be part two
of season pass after you know shadow
keep so that's my hope so
yeah I mean that's I would be ok with it
even I'm not as much of a PvP person as
you I've been getting into it you know
one more I mean I've played like off and
on over time I always don't mind going
to the playlist like sometimes it's fun
like I have my moments where I feel good
I think one of the pieces that would be
crucial for whether its shadow keep
whether it's destiny 3 and this is the
thing is where they say they want to fix
the foundation they want to fix the
fundamentals the playlists of PvP like
that's where I think the shadow keep is
gonna be more telling when it comes to
PvP is there gonna be a lone wolf
playlist right is there gonna be an
option to go like iron banner lone wolf
or like just check some of those boxes
and I think there might be a little more
willing to if they're knowing like
there's going to be an influx of free
people playing because you can write you
put a free game like destiny on Steam Oh
even if it's just something that
sometimes in the background
you don't have to buy that you can play
strikes crucible gambit old campaign you
can play all those things be like hey
want to go play pvp and these are like
and you could honestly say like okay we
have a decent I know and that's like the
difference of like the difference of the
population but you also will have more
of a population with new light going
everywhere
so yeah I'm so sorry about that one yeah
my next area yeah but I mean the big
three are gonna have a larger player
base in I mean it's gonna be there's no
way that thing doesn't do insanity on
Steam so many people aren't steaming
it's free how do you not add that in
your just occasional rotation of do you
want to play it's free it's late yeah
you'd be like hey you want to play this
this shooter with me a shooter at the
level of destiny
yeah just ask you a dime oh yeah that
one's yeah I mean that you can be like
hey what are free games on Steam yeah
these goofy little shoot-'em-ups are
arcades be like destiny it's like that
game
what are we though like that little
pause like those moments of free 99 is
gonna give that people a that population
base just a massive notion of like
I don't understand of massive I don't
know and sixty frames per second yeah go
check out go check that is one of the
best ports of a game I've ever seen in
my life that game on I mean the game on
console they have done so much with like
what they can and what can't wait to see
what's next gen can do but the port
feels like to me but feels even better
like only it's I can't go back I cross
the save is gonna be a thing but I will
mmm I can't go back you know you'd bring
in your guardian pact
I would pick up a controller and be like
I don't know how to do this anymore
oh I haven't used Rover on destiny and
so long I'm not saying I don't know how
to shoot but I know I would not be like
I'd be in PvP and I'd have like a 0.1
what if some some old friends from an
old claim come on help us out mostly
stop playing but so you won't even cross
see for like a day you wouldn't ascend
you wouldn't come down from the heavens
and I mean like
like hey there's a lot of like you play
your PlayStation can show I would like
if there was a point be like hey guys
I'm playing on PlayStation today I know
I haven't been in a while the nice thing
is at least the options there so if I do
one option the option is there and
that's the nice thing if there's a point
hey let me bring the PlayStation down
let's hook it up to the computer let's
stream let's have a PlayStation day I'm
probably gonna need to get carried but
at least I'll have my gear my equipments
my guns and all that soil is looking I'm
in fully leveled even if my skills with
my thumb suck at the moment but that's
how I will say this this is III um
tidbit got a chance to play X cloud oh
yeah oh boy
that is amazing that is let out grant
granted it was still somewhat of a
controlled environment going playing on
with an Xbox elite controller with like
a phone you know set up on top of it and
you had your screen and so on and so
forth I will say this with cross save I
would play destiny on the go if I'm
saying with a 4G LTE or a wireless
connection because I'm tell you right
now II they already testing it and I'm
playing Halo 5 60 frames per second no
discernible leg I don't again I can't
speak for anybody else's experience it I
would say it's the equivalent of what
you had like you know like there's a
game mode and there's not a game oh yeah
but your TV yeah it's like the same
thing like without game mode on I cannot
determine I make any discernible a and
I'm making cuts I'm moving and grooving
Don granese shooting everything's
responsive and literally was mind blown
by that now that is replicated when the
public trial comes out when it released
that is a cool option imagine like
you're just somewhere working on you
know what let me grind out some strikes
let me you know I'm saying and then
brawl on your job but yeah oh you know
oh you know that's to say you know
doctor's office so you know wherever
you're at you know and you just got time
to kill and we know destinies are grind
right we know that is a huge deal so I
think in situations like that it will
work but I agree like for the most part
coming from you know PC master-race now
it's kind of tough you know so I tell to
you like hey cross say works well well
you could come over here have
experienced this gloriousness know you
of people like I mean there's shout out
to follow plays I know he's on
PlayStation but he's got a cut he's got
a PC enough to like do what he does make
the content all those things so it's
like but it's like just the daunting
idea of grinding all that stuff and when
oh you know if you have a day job and
things like that I was like damn but if
now if it's just like let me boot up my
PC and I can do it's like yeah like he's
gonna have a lot of people on
PlayStation but now I can be like hey
doing a play on PC anybody on there cool
like cool you guys it's the option I
think that's gonna be big and just the
population to go with that will be it
with doctor cut you with new light man
yeah that's exactly what yeah yeah I
it's gonna be huge
yeah you the population influx from new
light is gonna be what I think allows
Bungie to have a little more freedom
with their kind of playlists cuz right
now it's literally like quick play
nobody cares about the middle slot
unless it's iron banner because Showdown
lockdown that's the rumble is there but
I don't even I feel like that's just a
of cares but like you don't have like I
can't go play specifically control or
rift or a lone wolf or like those aren't
an option and I feel like if you have
the free influx of people that they're
worried of the player base or long
matchmaking times or whatever hopefully
will be helped it's just kind of a hope
they have more freedom in their playlist
creation because the things they said is
like we're gonna revisit the playlist
and I've been wondering what that means
what do you I mean that's mine is like
is there so is there so low is there a
controller there clash is there your
competitive having a little more freedom
like are those mentors yeah or is it
more do you see like are they talking
about matchmaking are they talking about
like hey quick plays gonna have you know
power ammo at this time or I mean how do
you do you think it's that type of stuff
or like the actual like how you match
make like what do you think is their
channels they're talking about yeah I
think the vibe I get from them it seems
like they're making those taken King
system changes that that's the vibe I'm
getting which is beings like okay you
see how we're doing stuff whatever
version
then like vendors and stuff like that
and changing like what I call quality of
life right I think it's going to be that
I don't know if they're gonna go as far
as connection that would be dope that's
a big ask we all know you know their
situation in the past I'm not gonna go
too crazy with that dedicated service
exactly good three four next-gen yes yes
something like this yes so I mean I
think with I I / guy is let's see the
biggest complaints or that when you play
a quick play you can't really play what
you want like d1 d1 you can say hey I
just want to for the most part do this
you got a hope you know I mean rumbles
there but quick play seems to be like
this composite of things right so all d1
you should be able to do what you wanted
maybe they for patient but I think
they're gonna mess around with the
structure first and moulds that III
think that's where they're gonna go
first and see how it is you know and
then as it goes on you know then I think
we're probably that following season is
probably gonna be the more dedicated
push to hopefully like a trials or
hopefully things that communities really
really requesting so that's what I see I
got a question if you I want to give you
a sneak preview to a topic that we
actually onto an IO fee and um you know
actually King brought it up and I want
to see what your thoughts with which is
in reference to new life and it's
free-to-play model right and with this
inclusion now you're gonna get a lot a
lot of people would ask one play and
maybe stay on for a while right they got
that choice of whether you know hey I
don't maybe I don't like shadow keep
this one maybe I don't buy black but I
just buy this and like that hold at
least that's what they're hinting at
right that you can do with new life so
my own question is with this do you
think this now pushes d3 back even
further because it's conning it's free
to play model state
okay well shout out to DCP cuz
talking about this - oh I missed yeah
they were talking about the same thing
you and I'm talking about it many times
and you get to this point
EFT was basically saying and it's kind
of like it was the shift in cuz they
were asking like cuz data was on and
they're asking about when do you see a
d3 because you know he asked the
question to him on the stream yes Luke
and he kind of dodged it for now and
liked ft I would say before the stream
is like dude it's like you know probably
with next-gen in 2020 like come in feels
like a good time and then now he sounds
like feels like the tone is they can be
doing this thing for like three four
years if they just continue to build on
destiny - and that's kind of a point
where you have different you have things
like an engine like a mace level piece
of the game that has things like peer
based matchmaking or you have the way in
armor functions or the way like the
vault talks to your character or like
those certain things are like built so
deep there are certain systems that I
feel whatever system it is like those
are just random examples and they're
probably not everyone I'm talking about
but it's a point to where certain things
if they want big like I want to chop
this leg off of destiny and put a new
leg on that almost takes like a new
foundation to stand on take something
like a d3 correct so when Franta had a
guess of like 2021 actually so like
shadow keep something else with next gen
to keep it going to keep kind of d2
alive let it settle in to the next gen
consoles and then let people transition
to maybe that newer 60 and so like
that's the issue is like the next gen
you have and that's I think one of the
issues is like depending on what their
plane is when next gen comes out does
ps5 run it at 60 frames per second on
console Xbox Scarlett run 60 frames like
they have to but then like that console
game is not built for that
does it have filled abuse liners because
now it can handle it right as the GPU in
the photos are but that's the thing is
like is console being hampered out like
yeah it may look pretty but if you can't
get the higher for
you can't get the field of view you
can't get those things on console but
you know that damn machine can run it is
that a point where like is this next
year shadow keep of them like d3 still
in the month like if they're working on
d3 they already are working on it
there's no bus and everything everybody
can agree absolutely absolutely when it
comes is when I think they feel
comfortable with like the systems
they've had the trials they put through
like understanding like networking is
that gonna be the time for dedicated
servers like something like dedicated I
think has to come with d3 I don't think
the infrastructure of d2 is built for
that I don't know if that's and I'm not
a programmer so maybe it is something
you could change but that would be one
like literally hell of a communication
of how that game functions or to work so
connection yeah we connect you know
crazy oh no you're good you're good oh
I'm literally taking a breath I'm just
like saying a lot of word vomit over
like I don't know like d3 and 2020 still
feels like something that's possible cuz
you would have had year 1 forsaken
shadow keep here that'd be 3 years but
also they lost a couple Studios they put
a shadow keep they stick with this
annual pass as you said before when
you're like well there's three other
that's for like four more seasons when
is the break-up when'd it when does the
time that they need to be like that when
does Luke come out and this time he's
just like he's got to be candid again
we're not gonna kill our developers but
we do want there are some changes we
can't do to D to the D 3 requires so
this next season is gonna have two
passes and it's gonna be like a six
month little little to maybe little
bigger box here but it's gonna be
there's gonna have to be some downtime
like whenever those things are finally a
point of reality for them 20 20 21
actually what I mean when friend said
that it sounded like that I could see
four years away France a friend with
fair friend was saying about 2021 Wow so
I mean cuz that gives them another year
that's an e a year after shadow keep
that lets the x-gen consuls get out
there Valley brand-new settled in rocket
a decent base but I also don't think
it's like 2024 where they live indeed
you know
that long yeah I don't see their I don't
agree yep yeah sounds like I think I'm
somewhere in like if they've been in d3s
development for long enough maybe 20 20
if they feel like they can make enough
changes or it's there if next gen
consoles seem daunting and 2021 is
probably where I think it almost needs
to be yeah I don't think it can be past
2021 I would be okay with it being there
because I can understand the reasons for
it if they slow down development like d2
fades somewhat they're gonna keep the
live stuff they'll they'd have less all
that crap I've said before um but I
don't think you can go farther than that
fourth year because then I feel like d2
has some fundamental things that still
has to fix and I think the way they do
that is a d3 and I think that's that's a
problem that's if that answers your
question in the most no you'd literally
answer yeah like I'd literally because
I'm saying mindset I think there's still
even though free-to-play model may be
something they continue with with this
new light stuff and they kind of
grandfather it in but I do think that
there's fundamental engine things that
they want to be able to do with d3 that
they currently cannot do with d2 and I'm
firm believer that cross play is also
one of them so and they've said they
won't yeah and they say they want to
yeah yeah and I just don't know how like
ps4 and Xbox on there like 30 frames per
second can I don't know how you talk
like two people on either side is like I
mean I know like dauntless does it but
it's like some of those things they're
it's not the same looking game like
dauntless and more tonight do not have
the fidelity I'm sorry it's not it's
just the same as like Monster Hunter
verse dauntless like I'm sorry but play
the detail there yeah they looked like
they both have their own styles but like
you're talking about high fidelity like
stuff sitting on there so no I'm with
you that there are two there are some
deep things built into the game I mean
set read was like loading screens yeah I
mean console on like be alive xbox
Scarlett those are gonna be those are
gonna have the CPU to handle that type
of stuff and then of course the crazy
SSDs and stuff but it's like
see who has been one of the biggest
things is something like I don't know
Spencer somebody I said like they have
the graphics to be able to do more it's
this abuse that can't keep up with the
that's what the current gen now yeah
yeah with the current gen of saying like
ps4 and Xbox currently yeah they do more
even a pro level but you're still
talking about like the checker boys but
right they're so old and they can't keep
track like 600 days on screen like
there's that's the type of stuff they
can't process like the AI and like but
and that's somebody yeah where do I
catch it once there's some interview or
something they're just the amount of
enemies in a space for them to function
the way they do and they can't have too
many with the current consoles yeah
absolutely that's a fact that's a fact
that but again you know in the future
width is and we only get to techie but
no design in the Navi situations that's
supposedly coming with both the
playstation fibers call it that part
would be alleviated I think again once
those things kind of get set up I agree
I think I don't know if they necessarily
want to launch in conjunction with new
consoles I think I agree with you that
it's probably another wait period and
get a gray shaded with the hardware and
then bring d3 out on it so I could see
2021 to an extent to I could kind of see
2021 cuz again we figure for 2020 new
consoles I can't see them launching you
know and let unless it's across
generation they did here's the only
thing I worry about when destiny one
launched it was a cross-generational
title because it launched on a 360 and
ps3 we go and we converted even though
ps4 and Xbox one work out so I'm very
curious to see if they go back that
route or you know I think this comes
down and went probably when they're
ready just one name it when they're
absolutely ready and they they feel
cause I mean we're just curious yeah
like if you do d3 I feel like and I feel
like something like the the triangle
ships deserves d3 yes I don't think you
can do justice with the shadow keep the
triangle ships have been
for five years what they need I just
don't I don't think you can do that Lord
Justice with an expansion in my mind now
maybe if it's like forsaken shadow keep
taking King smash like some insanity
level buret yeah I just don't know if
you can know so that's those are like
those that's a that would be an amazing
launching point it's a new race you have
cross Jim cross play like dedicated
servers like you just say all those like
five words or like phrases I like that
game sells itself like South baby oh so
what they do it day one that's why
people so talk about just cross same for
an event like wow absolutely so yeah
there's a lot to speculate on shadow
keep with armor 2.0 whatever verse
ornaments changing so you got transmog
situations coming bright dust kind of
get in it's a little adjustment which I
think I'm gonna be ok with like I've
earned a lot from my cosmetic engrams
just like breaking down ghosts and ships
and extra stuff like that so I was like
I'm hoping I can still earn a decent
amount but the process was what was
always flawed just I having to break
something down yeah yeah they're in
there if you want to like if you do your
bow music yeah like you can do those and
I have so many notes that I probably
need to do that while I can because
those go away but outside of that like
there's a lot of huge positive steps
Bungie is looking to be just leading
their own ship
they've steered it in a good direction
and yeah it's just been amazing to watch
what they've done so but yeah it's wrap
things up the Bungie take pride pin if
you guys haven't seen it it's freaking
awesome rainbow pin it's for everybody
who you want to help support all
proceeds go to the It Gets Better
Project and it basically is a mission to
uplift empower and connect lesbian gay
bisexual transgender queer youth around
the globe and just to let I mean
inclusion round inclusion is huge
because the things that you go through
is especially a teenager growing up
going through puberty and then if
feel like you're backwards and broken
and everything else and you have nobody
to talk to about it I can i I came out I
was like I came out as just a
heterosexual guy and I had enough I was
like and there's enough issues growing
up with being nervous insecured peer
pressure and so much and now with social
media I there's a reason I'm not parent
more power to all those out there like
there is so much out there with social
media so if you fall into LGBTQIA like
Amy and all of that stuff if they can
support that then do it and it's an
amazing looking pin to just a rainbow
the logo for bungee so they did want to
shout that out it was sold out right now
but just put your email in there it'll
come up when it's available to keep
restocking I just didn't want to not
mention that one because it is no we
have like which means guardians are like
for st. Jude's taking care of all that
and then this one for just inclusion of
because honestly you you never know and
and it's like no and yeah so honestly
it's like the reality is this there's a
lot of people who are suffering silence
silence you know and I love gay friends
and you'd be surprised you know I'm
saying the stories you hear and just to
be treated just as anyone else make
someone's day you know say and that's
why I like again with the st. Jude stuff
now this in the Pride Month and oh it's
great you know I'm saying like again
what more can you say about this game in
the community just new positive things
and that's why I'm proud that's why I
always got my chest out for destiny
because like I said a podcast wouldn't
have started without definite you know
they forget which one was it was a
PlayStation King also in his chest
basically through the screen for destiny
and I laughed my butt off when King did
his like little rapper not rapper just
like he was kind of dropping like a
lyrical like a rhyme talking about this
thing coming at me right now I lost it
when I heard that one I was like so good
King a fist bump for me for that one
because I lost my stuff in the cuz they
would do a destiny slander and cake
would have none of it shake the good
word about that's great I forgot about
that
great it's good it's good to see you
don't say it's good this stuff is good
to see so yeah support how do you get
the pin now so I won't know did you buy
it from the store I just gotta get one
it's in stock it sold out fast and
they're trying to get more so just go to
the store when you go to the page even
if it says out of stock on the bottom
right I'll have this little thing email
when available so 3 email in there when
it's in there do it they said they're
gonna try and restock it a few more
times so if you can and that's the cool
thing about the store everything from
their store goes proceeds like goes
straight I mean it's like it's basically
non profit but they send everything I
can not to their pocket so that's why
it's like whether it's the rain jacket
whether it's the like ornaments whether
it's the pins you're going for like mmm
it all goes the good things so it's
always there amazing so salute but yeah
that is about all I've got this week you
have anything else you want to throw out
there I don't know if you're about to
fall asleep on me on stream but I'm
hurting
but I wanted a shout out I've got a
guest coming on next week we had a
little more warning on this one so I
actually get to tell you guys who's
coming whoa
so next week we've got cool guy if you
guys haven't seen him he'll work this
man up on YouTube he's got I cannot wait
to get him he could does not seem like a
nicer guy great reviews on web
he seems like just the cool name I'm a
cool guy like he is but it's right you
like cool guys like I like I'm a tool
seems like the nicest guy like if you
buy him just be just cool dude so I
cannot wait for next week we've got him
coming on and it will be similar
timeframe so I think the time will work
but we'll get him on next week so spread
the word watch Twitter spread the word
around we want I want I want chat like
rolling next to it come on we gotta get
a lot of people in there so we'll do
some pro I'll do some promo as well no
guy when you told me I was like wow
that's big like I follow his content I
came across his content and he just has
a very dope style you know I'm saying
and very you actually reminds me you are
in a sense that it's just very mr. Tom
Thoreau um
gray shading like he brings in you know
and I just love listening to you know
what one thing I'd love as a PvP player
listening him review something he
definitely does it in a way he actually
can sometimes show you things that
people say are useless and fine
functionality and yeah my are okay heavy
I can traverse whole to him you know
we're gonna do it up from it cook up a
nice little intro for the cool one no so
that is gonna be next week that'll be
the 28th same time same bat Channel all
that stuff will be here as you guys know
this is on the audio platforms I want a
shout out to everybody for audio as well
lately we hit like a hundred and fifty
views on two weeks ago when you still
were here even the one just where I had
the guest on you guys jumped into
discord god I mean we're averaging like
130 views and it's like four and like
audio podcast like thank you guys that
was amazing seriously so audio support
y'all very much impressive for us being
new to the platform and just to see that
when he shows me the numbers I'm like
damn this is really impressive
so definitely salute to you guys for
supporting man definitely if you can't
cut just like I said on Twitter YouTube
and you know extend audio is the way it
seems like for us audio is the way if I
got it yeah I was like so keep it going
keep that trend going on spread tell
your friends if they like destiny or two
guys who love it too so next week
tune in it's gonna be next Friday's last
word 28 same time like probably 8
o'clock for start maybe you know we'll
see just make sure but normal start time
should be good and that's the one right
before Guardian con so we'll see we're
like we'll see what dr. Lupo does we'll
see about this heroic mode and honestly
I just can't wait to just have another
guest in here so it's always a ton of
fun and we're always working on more
guess so Guardian con networking we'll
see if we can line up some stuff so we
got do someone I would reach out today
to the crew you know saying that we've
had P and also people we've actually had
on the show before you'll see what's up
with them as well and something some big
fishes from oh yeah they'll be late all
right well thank you guys very much
yeah cogniat on what you got coming and
he got the fun times on Sunday oh wait
yes every Sunday I'll or podcast YouTube
one
p.m. Eastern check it out man we're
gonna have actually two people you know
pretty well we're gonna have arm gaming
forte and slow-mo back slap make their
debut on the in the realm of the laws I
gotta get you back it's been a minute
for you now we're like September 17 yeah
oh yeah okay yes now you know what's it
like our tradition oh my god just
because usually when it's the big big
release I'll have you yeah that'll be
your comeback yeah yeah it was pencil
pencil that one and I should be in
shout out the mill melter what's up man
yeah we will have a Forte long-overdue
hardcore we got a destiny fan I gave you
a preview of one of the topics if you
reference to the free-to-play stuff
versus d3 and how to handle it and of
course the legendary [ __ ] backstab
division lover Borderlands level ooh the
shooter stuff so we're gonna have some
nice topics check us out there with them
talk a lot and then um what else is
going on man so much is going on still
look out for more III content tons of
content I'm sitting on tons of articles
and you know I got come in and um yeah
shout out for the support for the
cyberpunk behind-the-scenes interview
stuff we did as well as I'm a lot of the
Nintendo stuff solicit Zelda's Link
Link's Awakening working yeah put that
up and um but I was paying so much
content so again please if you can
please get a chance check out Lords of
gaming net a lot of contents up there if
you want to check out what happened at
e3 and our oppressions and all the hard
work that the team has done please
support us but and you already know the
last word man every Friday gotta be here
too I found a list before we go pray for
all the gamers out there in September
this is the big stuff dropping in
September and this is why we're all
gonna cry a little bit you with Lords of
gaming me trying to cover anything
besides this game this is literally the
list and this is just some of the bigger
ones monster underworld ice board in
September 6 gears 5 September cents
Borderlands 3 September 13 destiny -
shadow keep September 17th if you play
fifa that September 19 Link's Awakening
on September 20th Nino - September 20th
as well you've got
by day like contra code vain requests
dead by daylight says switch September
24th oh my god
code vain November 27th somebody's got a
blink somebody this is instant
somebody's got to blink that is insane
start to finish and all those guy your
games are like I want game they're all
grindy there are a lot of them are long
like legend de velde is not short
ninokuni is an RPG FIFA you've got your
grind
I don't even play FIFA but I know it's
long you've got that's the to shadow
keep of course Borderlands 3 nothing but
a grind Monster Hunter world that was
200 hours the first time gears live I'm
sure there's gonna be a hormone PDP code
vein Dark Souls that's killing yourself
like holy mother of like that is insane
so I just wanted to shout that out cuz I
was like looking for a list and I had
the page open and never went back and
said it but oh my god September's it
stop it like don't give me a break
we were already complaining with say
wait I forgot gears as an it up this
isn't say yeah I don't know what I'm
gonna do down mom dad that might be like
you gotta take some time off work figure
out I need to somehow by another
September just to traffic I can i buy
another September play like Link's
Awakening and code vein and then come
back and play shadow keep like been days
there we need more release yeah I just
saw that list that was like I had to say
that cuz I was like yeah in case you
wonder if there's other games oh my god
there ever are and September's gonna
kill us all so insane well yeah for me
you guys know where to find me
as I said the voice has been even
struggling today so I probably won't
even do much today because I used it but
twitch Twitter YouTube you guys know
where to find me if you are looking to
make any donations you got even 5 bucks
sitting around that donation is still
just going to the Guardian con st.
jude's cause that link is in chat if you
guys want to help support again the kids
that is all for they're just trying to
see if even through all of you guys out
there if you can do if we can get 500
bucks that just had to be kind of a cool
thing to say that we donated you know
five hundred to it so Eenie a little bit
$5 one no it doesn't matter
every little bit counts remember it's
like $32 a second to run that place and
it adds up fast so thank you guys for
everything it's a bond to sever if you
haven't if you're subscribed to the
YouTube channel hit that little alert
Bell both on my channel and iron Lords
podcast because the way YouTube goes you
never know if you're actually getting in
anybody's feet or not yeah absolutely
man hit that hit that low alarm button
man inhales time you don't you don't
miss any of our content and I bounces
out here working still putting up great
content
hopefully the voice gets healed and then
consistent power for this magazine that
sexy voice going on the exact little bit
what's up